whether you are trying to book a car
rental for vacation or perhaps need a
car while your car is being fixed you
probably have found it is really tough
to find a rental without spending a
whole lot of dough correct so eight news
now reporter madison kimber actually
spoke with a company that is giving
people an alternative to the traditional
rental car process it definitely was not
easy i would say they maybe had too many
vans left and when i looked elsewhere in
other
sites like avis or other ones they
didn't have any minivans
as summer travel approaches locals like
adele newberry says she just needed a
ride for her and her kids while their
car was in the shop every time i looked
it got higher and higher so whenever i
switched platforms the price would go
down and she's not alone as the process
to find a rental car on a week's notice
has become a challenge with many having
to book it out months in advance so
that's where companies like turo steps
in described as the world's largest car
sharing market placed guests have the
option to choose from a selection of
over thirteen hundred makes and models
we're in well over seventy five hundred
cities including uh las vegas
where you can book from localhost prices
vary but finding an affordable and
available car on a week's notice is very
possible mikey del rosario recalls using
the service just after lockdown during
the pandemic and says it helped him out
so much that he decided to become a host
himself it's been going really well
actually it's booked like almost every
day
i love driving the car and sometimes i'm
like oh man it's booked again madison
kimbrough live local now